Floyd Mayweather and dj khaled are in
trouble with the SEC these guys promoted
on their social media cryptocurrency
token offerings and specifically implied
returns which is something the SEC never
looks kindly on if Boyd Mayweather
cannot read
how could he have committed
cryptocurrency for all I know about
cryptocurrency is that you give somebody
$5,000 and then a year later you have
$3,000 X yeah it's like buying a winery
Floyd Mayweather the boxer and dj khaled
the person were promoting this
cryptocurrency company but it turns out
they were doing it because they've been
paid to promote it and not as we all
thought because they are economic
experts and needed to share their wisdom
with the world surely Mayweather at
least knows what he's doing his nickname
is money surely he's good at getting it
my nickname at school was
[Applause]
stop trusting what you read on the
Internet
it's not trustworthy and a men has
13,000 followers unspotted I not eminem
and a men which means 13,000 people
misspelled Eminem and then followed that
playlist okay so don't get financial
advice from baby brain mayweather and
shitty music DJ khaled
you